mind your decisions i'm preshtal walker
a sack contains four different colored
balls
that are colored blue yellow red
and pink of these 14 are not blue
16 are not yellow 24 are not red
and 12 are not pink how many balls
are there in the sack a version of this
problem
was asked in india pause the video if
you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
suppose the total number of balls in the
sack is equal to s
also suppose that there are b blue balls
y yellow balls are red balls and p
pink balls because the sac contains
exactly these four different colors
s is equal to b plus y plus r plus p
we also know that 14 balls are not blue
that means 14 is equal to s minus b
16 balls are not yellow this means 16 is
equal to s
minus y 24 balls are not red
which means 24 is equal to s minus r
and finally 12 balls are not pink that
means 12 is equal to s
minus p we now have a system of
equations let's take these four
equations and add them together the
left-hand side
will be equal to the sum of these
numbers which is equal to 66.
the right-hand side will be equal to 4s
minus 1 of each color so we subtract
b we subtract y we subtract r and we
subtract
p but we know that
s is the sum of b y r and p
therefore this term will be equal to
negative s
we'll substitute that in we then have 4s
minus s which is equal to 3s
thus 66 is equal to 3s we divide both
sides by 3
and get that s is equal to 22.
so it would seem there are exactly 22
balls in the sack
but wait does this answer make any sense
to find out let's calculate the number
of balls of each color
we'll substitute into these equations
and solve for each variable
from the first equation we'll get that b
is equal to eight
from the second y is equal to six from
the third
r is equal to negative two and from the
last equation p is equal to ten
but wait r is equal to negative two
this makes no sense the number of red
balls
should be a non-negative number
therefore
this entire problem is nonsensical
the correct answer is that there is no
solution
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time
you